so here's max
and
his numbers and a big time arsenal to
take to the mound with him yeah last
start recorded his first 10k game of the
season seven innings two hits 104
pitches
so he's going for his 100th career 10 or
more strikeout game here today all right
tommy edmonds in there an inside
fastball and tommy edmond is on base
leading off the game nolan arnado is two
for nine one of his hits a double
and a ground ball
off the glove of the third baseman
castro no play as trey turner was there
to back it up and a base hit for nolan
arnado here's paul de young batting
cleanup
and he walked him and the base is loaded
for dylan carlson who owns a grand slam
this year carlson is struck out 15 times
this year make it 16. biggest pitch of
the game right there for scherzer
two now needed it
went to the slider i believe here so two
out bases loaded chance to get out of it
here if he can get matt carpenter
upstairs
swing
and a miss
and max scherzer does what max does best
the strikeout for the last two of the
top of the first and now the home half
of the first carlos martinez
this season three starts
it's just been the one
inning that has gotten him and then
outside of that he pitches well
and it's lifted in the air right field
long way to go but tommy edmond is there
to make the catch
here's a one-two pitch outfield is
straight away
popped up to the right side going out
the second baseman carpenter called off
by edmond to make the catch one two
three
max scherzer back to work inning number
two rolls in and the 3-2 pitch with a
shift on the right side
and williams
picks up a base hit into center the
second cardinal hit of the afternoon and
a line drive single for williams brings
kisner to the plate runner goes again
swinging a miss the throw right there
strike him out throw him out double play
a bullet from alex avila to complete it
and that's why you got to get a good
jump not just a bullet check out the
quick release by avila here because pick
7 through 11
as martinez rips it fair down into the
corner
what did he jump on that pitch for a
double
well i think if you're thinking at the
plate
and you're hitting and you get a
changeup
look at him as a pitcher you got to be
looking fastball at the next pitch
so here's josh who's two for 15 career
against
carlos martinez
up the middle paul's got some hair on it
aronado pops up and
safe is the call
goldschmidt couldn't dig it out
josh was at the bag at the time and you
would
assume it's going to be a hit now alex
avila making his third start behind the
plate he's looking for his first hit
hole for sex international's uniform
well that ball is stung to the camp and
left center by avila here comes josh
bell
bob henley's going to send him
on a rough relay by the cardinals and
the gnats are on top nationals lead
one to nothing
the relay from the outfield made the
shortstop to young
move to his right and have to whirl all
the way around to make a throw
and when bobby henley saw that
he waved bell around third and the relay
throw off the mark it's a double for
avila for his first hit as a national we
go to the third inning max and the
nationals have a one-nothing lead over
the cardinals be paul goldschmidt to
lead it off for st louis
oh that's going to get the inside edge
front door on the slider strikeout
number four yeah goldschmidt aronado de
young they're big guns today
oh he's going to paint the inside edge
with the fastball that time and that'll
tie max with mike mussina for number 21
on the all-time list feel he needed to
go to the injured list he could have
been available to pinch it or dh next
week here's the crown ball softly toward
short charging into young and it's right
under his glove and out into left center
field and stevenson ran through the bag
or he might have had a chance to go to
second because no one in the outfield
really made a move for it figuring that
was going to be a fairly routine play
here's josh harrison fly to left he's
hitting second in the order the
2-2
out to left williams going back oh he
made the catch on the edge of the track
what a play justin williams
right in front of the warning track and
having to scamper back to first is
andrew stevenson that was a terrific
play by justin williams he leaped into
the air and
hauled it in nicely done
i don't think they thought it was going
to get caught either nice play
it's a really nice play
two up two away and here is justin
williams who singled against max in the
second inning
foul tip
swing and a strikeout
number six so max scherzer passed
mike mussina for 21st place with two
thousand eight hundred and fourteen
strikeouts
orinato
went away
and that's all you have to do you don't
have to do it to everyone you just gotta
let everyone know you can do it and you
will do it
and he picks up his strikeout his
second of the afternoon now max working
quickly over the head into the wine one
and two
and he gets another
number seven for scherzer and now we're
starting to think about that ten
strikeout thing
not easy to sit and watch john gomez
catch three or four days in a row and
then come out and do what he's doing
today
look at this
he's gonna hook one down right field way
hustling to first
he's gonna keep on going the throw from
edmond bounces high and that gets avila
in there with a hustle double a pair of
doubles today he saw edmond going away
from the play he knew he had to put the
brakes on and go spin move then he goes
late tough slide stays on the base
three balls two strikes
the wind in the pitch
swinging a ground ball up the middle
across the bag is harrison to backhand
off-balance throw is low scoop by bell
nice play both ends they get the out
harrison started on the right of second
crossed over to the left
and with the off-balance cross the body
throw gets goldschmidt it's a real nice
play here's arenado
swing and a miss on a cutter
that had so much break on it
it ended up way outside and that's
number eight maybe he needs to empty the
tank here to get this third out dylan
carlson a strikeout a pop-up to short
swing
and a miss
number nine for scherzer if that's it
he's retired 13 of his last 14 and still
able to blow a guy away fp this late in
the game turner advances to third base
he's there with two outs
annie got him
strikeout for martinez that is number
three
and the cardinals are not done yet as
and that'll load the bases for matt
carpenter
and carpenter hits it well to right but
stevenson is there and the cardinals
leave them loaded now the nats have two
saves this year brad hand has both of
them
at 31 years old 6-3 215.
so two pitches fastball slider about
50-50 fastball 92 slider 80.
oh and he misses away
tying runs aboard
kisner is next
oh baby this is what the nats were
looking for harrison turns it six four
three two down for molina
elena the pinch hitter in the last hope
for the cardinals
and for the stretch all the time kicks
and delivers and a breaking ball hit in
the air to right field stevenson to his
left toward the line now back and makes
the catch just before crossing onto the
warning track and bang zuma curly w's in
the books
24 in a row
for brad hand three for three as a net